yeah I hate to tell you but you're wrong
about the Constitution it's not your
fault I mean that thing is like seven
pages long who has time to read that and
there's like two dozen amendments
but it's not your fault everyone is
wrong about the Constitution
think about this phrase from each
according to his ability to each
according to his needs in 1987 the
Hearst Corporation conducted a survey to
Mark the bicentennial of the U.S
Constitution over 50 percent of survey
participants thought that that phrase
from each according to his ability to
each according to his needs was part of
the US Constitution and this wasn't a
one-off result according to a 2002
Columbia Law School study nearly
two-thirds of persons pulled thought
that this phrase came from the
Constitution or from one of the founding
fathers but this phrase does not appear
in the Constitution James Madison the
author of The Constitution didn't say it
either so who did well this was written
by none other than Karl Marx in 1875 and
then parodied by George Orwell in Animal
Farm Marx wasn't the first person to
articulate this idea Scholars traced the
concept to the new testament which
states in part and distribution was made
unto every man according as he had need
now the Soviet Union eventually
Incorporated the slogan into its
Constitution as quote from each
according to his ability to each
according to his his work but that has
never appeared in the U.S Constitution
so you can imagine if Americans confuse
the US Constitution with the Soviet
Constitution they're probably wrong
about a whole bunch of other things
let's talk about it one thing that
people get wrong all the time is
thinking that the constitution mandates
that English is the official language of
the United States that same 1987 hearse
survey found that 64 percent of the
people believed that the Constitution
made English the official national
language of America but English as the
official language has never been part of
the Constitution although English was
the dominant language at the time the
Constitution was ratified many other
languages flourished as well the most
common languages included Dutch French
German and the many languages spoken by
Native Americans enslaved people spoke
African languages as well as made their
own english-based Creole languages and
most of the founding fathers favored
bilingual education Thomas Jefferson
spoke English French Italian Latin and
he could also read Greek and Spanish he
hoped that America would establish
colleges that would teach in French
Spanish German and other languages
others like Ben Franklin saw it
differently and said things that were
incredibly offensive and malthusian
saying quote those Germans who come
hither are generally the most ignorant
stupid sort of their own Nation they
will soon outnumber us that all the
advantages we have will not in my
opinion be able to preserve our language
and even our government will become
precarious
luckily he didn't win the day on that
one now states with large German
populations disagreed with Ben Franklin
at least initially in the 1800s
Pennsylvania and Ohio passed laws
allowing German to be taught in public
schools of course however Americans have
consistently attempted to limit these
speaking of other languages in this
country politicians have tried to
introduce Constitutional Amendment
making English the official language
which would force the government to stop
providing bilingual services so far
these efforts have failed and while a
constitutional amendment hasn't passed
Congress historically has passed all
kinds of laws that would prevent people
from speaking non-english languages for
example in the 19th century the
government forced Native American
children to attend missionary schools in
1887 the Bureau of Indian Affairs
decided that Mission schools on
reservations were required to provide
all instruction in English children who
use their own languages were bullied and
beaten by the instructors this of course
led to immense language loss and of
course French was the dominant language
in the Louisiana Territory for over a
hundred years the first Louisiana
constitutions made English and French
the official dual languages of the state
but Louisiana was a Melting Pot for
different ethnic groups and eventually
their dialects merged to produce what we
call Louisiana French but in 1921
Louisiana adopted a new state
constitution which reversed the policy
of bilingual rights the state banned the
teaching of French in all public schools
which highlights one of the differences
between the U.S federal Constitution and
individual state constitutions but of
course these Trends continue to this day
representative Louis Gomer introduced
the English language Unity Act of 2021
which would declare English as the quote
official language of the United States
to establish a uniform English language
rule for naturalization and to avoid
misconstructions of the English language
texts of the laws of the United States
pursuant to congress's power to provide
for the general welfare of the United
States and to establish uniform rule of
naturalization under Article 1 Section 8
of The Constitution of course the reason
that Gomer wanted to pass this law is
because it's not in the Constitution at
all and Gomer's bill was referred to
committee where it died but putting
language aside surely That Old Chestnut
no taxation without representation found
its way into the Constitution right well
the popular history of the American
Revolution goes something like this the
colonists got so fed up with King George
III's high taxes that they chucked
British tea into the Boston Harbor
decided Americans would henceforth
become coffee Drinkers and wrote a
constitution ensuring that no one would
ever be taxed again without being
adequately represented well as a
resident of the District of Columbia I
would have to take issue with this
particular summary of American history
in the 1700s the colonists objected to
the Stamp Act and other similar laws
that impose taxes on them because they
couldn't vote and didn't have
representation in Parliament and in
response the English came up with a
theory of virtual representation which
meant that since Parliament existed
every British subject was represented
regardless of whether they could vote of
course the young American colonists
didn't exactly take to this early
version of Zoom meetings after all the
pontificating about taxes and voting and
the subsequent war of independence
perhaps the biggest surprise of all is
that the taxation without representation
didn't make it into the final cut of the
Constitution though the colonists did
try hard to work it into the founding
documents the Articles of Confederation
Incorporated a we hate taxes stance by
denying the federal government the right
to Levy taxes at all this sounded cool
on paper but was a really big mess in
reality because the new government
couldn't pay its War debts it also
couldn't raise enough money for an army
or navy the British occupied forts in
the Great Lakes while also dumping its
convicts into the colonies and so for
this and many other reasons the
Americans had to write a new governing
document that eventually became the
Constitution and you had better well
believe that it gave the federal
government the right to Levy taxes the
problem is they forgot to mention that
in order to Levy taxes everyone needed P
adequately represented the state and
local authorities also got the power to
Levy taxes but the end result is that
the Constitution doesn't guaranteed no
taxation without representation but the
motto was still a rallying cry for the
disenfranchised populations especially
in the nation's capital where I live
Washington DC which is also the only
geographical entity in the contiguous
United States whose citizens must pay
taxes and register for Selective Service
without having political representation
in Congress well at least political
representation that can actually do
something DC residents pay more taxes
than residents in 22 States and pay more
money per capita to the federal
government than any actual State now we
are not the only ones who else pays
taxes without representation while
undocumented immigrants pay about seven
billion dollars a year in taxes inmates
pay taxes and so do formally
incarcerated people even if their voting
rights have not been restored American
children work and pay sales tax and
income tax but they lack the
representation of a vote and that's just
the tip of the iceberg there's a whole
bunch of taxation without representation
in the United States and that's probably
because the Constitution doesn't
guarantee that right Americans hate
taxes but they love shopping and a lot
of people think that they have a right
to enter a particular store or at least
they have a right to contract with other
people the freedom to contract this guy
believes he has a constitutional right
to eat at the Trump Grill in New York
City but here the police officer
contends that a reservation is not a
constitutional right I can't revoke my
resume that's a guarantee it's not a
constitutional right the protester is in
fact wrong about his constitutional
right to keep his dinner reservation but
this is an interesting question do
people have a constitutional right to
enter a store or a restaurant the
Constitution is often silent about most
things so it shouldn't be surprising
that no one has an explicit reference to
where people are allowed to be but the
1980 U.S Supreme Court case Pruneyard
shopping center versus Robbins said that
the constitution does not give people an
absolute right to enter and remain on
private property even if they intend to
exercise their First Amendment right to
free expression so if this man wants to
get into a restaurant to protest he
doesn't actually have a constitutional
right to do so despite the First
Amendment but what about if the city or
state government has imposed a
vaccination requirement to enter does
that violate the constitution well so
far the answer is no because not all
unequal treatment violates federal or
state laws the Civil Rights Act of 1964
explicitly prohibits restaurants from
refusing service to customers based on
race color religion or national origin
a restaurant can't refuse service to
black people or white people or Muslims
or atheists for example but when it
comes to other classes of people it's a
complete toss-up they can do what they
want restaurants and business owners
have argued that they have a religious
right to refuse service to Gay and
transgender people because of the
owner's religious beliefs now the
Supreme Court has yet to definitively
settle that issue and it's going to be
very interesting to see what happens
with the Supreme Court over the next few
years on this particular issue it's
definitely going to come up but when a
local regulation prevents unvaccinated
people from entering a restaurant which
is what happened with the situation in
New York City we're not talking about a
protected or quasi-protected class of
people based on their race ethnicity or
gender that means a lower standard of
review in other words rational basis
review which basically no law ever fails
so the bottom line is that the
constitution is not going to protect
your dinner reservation if there is a
specific enforceable law that says you
can't go inside then there is a phrase
that I think everyone is familiar with
the idea that the criminal law presumes
a that you are innocent until proven
guilty now that idea that you are
presumed innocent until proven guilty is
one of the most significant principles
in American law the rights of criminal
defense are very much part of the
Constitution for example the Fifth
Amendment bars self-incrimination quote
no person shall be compelled in any
criminal case to be a witness against
himself this is known as the right to
remain silent the sixth amendment
requires that people be given a speedy
and impartial jury trial an attorney in
criminal prosecutions and establishes
defendant's right to confront adverse
Witnesses and the 14th Amendment
provides for due process of law however
the Constitution does not require that a
state prove that someone committed a
crime Beyond Reasonable Doubt and the
Constitution doesn't say that you're
innocent until proven guilty now I'm not
saying that the concept of innocent
until proven guilty is not important but
the bigger point is that not all
fundamental rights can be sourced
directly to a line of text in the
Constitution astute Legal Eagles
probably already know that many of our
important legal principles come from
English common law but the presumption
of innocence has a more complicated
origin story it isn't found in any of
the sources we traditionally cite for
for English common law like the Magna
Carta or the English Bill of Rights of
1689 or treatises by Coke and Blackstone
in fact this presumption comes from
Roman law and canon law which form the
common law of Europe and eventually this
principle made its way into common law
in a very roundabout way in coffin
versus the United States the Supreme
Court held that the presumption of
innocence was a Bedrock Concept in the
American Criminal Justice System then
Justice white credited this to an Irish
jurist named Leonard McNally McNally was
known as a zealous advocate for Irish
defendants who were accused of treason
and during McNally's lifetime the
British system required two witnesses to
prove someone guilty of treason unless
the accused was Irish in which case one
witness was sufficient after McNally's
death the English press found out that
despite his years of advocacy for the
presumption of Irish innocence McNally
was in fact a double agent he
represented Irish revolutionaries in
court but reported on their activities
to prosecutors for at least 26 years
despite McNally's dubious role as a
double agent for the government today
the principle of innocent until proven
guilty is fundamental to the criminal
justice system in the United States
despite it having no reference
whatsoever in the Constitution itself
now that's just the tip of the iceberg
of things that you're wrong about the
Constitution but this video isn't over
because there's another legal eagle
video about even more things that you're
wrong regarding the Constitution not you
obviously but your friends probably
things like the filibuster and the
separation of church and state and this
full-length companion video exists
exclusively on nebula because sadly if I
put it on YouTube it'd probably get
demonetized and there's no way that
you'd ever see it but nebula is
different as you've probably heard by
now nebula is home to tons of exclusive
ad-free content like my first
full-length documentary bad law words
good exclusive videos on the legal
rights that you definitely don't want to
use anti-slap laws and tons tons more
all of this exclusive content is only on
nebula and you can get it for free with
curiosity stream of course the reason
all of these videos are exclusively
available on nebula is because they
probably just wouldn't work on YouTube
YouTube because of the way that the site
works on the other hand nebula has a
different platform without an algorithm
and without any ads because nebula is a
place where we can experiment with
content put things on there that we just
couldn't put on YouTube it's where I put
all of my videos ad free and usually
extended or with a completely exclusive
companion video I usually post my videos
a day or two early as well nebula is
Creator owned and operated like with my
friends half as interesting Marquez
Brownlee real life Lord Mike Boyd and
tons of others there's new exclusive
content released multiple times every
day and by the way we've been developing
nebula like crazy nebula now has apps
for iOS Android Apple TV Roku Fire TV
and Android TV my fellow creators and I
really care about nebula and we're
thrilled to be partnering with curiosity
stream because they are the go-to source
for the best documentaries and long-form
educational content on the internet they
even have an entire section devoted to
Unsolved Mysteries and crime so if you
like my videos you'll love the stuff on
curiosity stream and the best way to get
access to nebula and all the incredible
content is definitely through the
amazing cure curiosity stream nebula
bundle with its current sales price of
less than 15 dollars per year to get
full access to both sites and to be
clear that nebula subscription is not a
trial it's free for as long as your
curiosity stream member there just isn't
a better deal in streaming where you get
two streaming sites both with content
you'll actually watch and enjoy for less
than fifteen dollars per year at the
current sales price but what's more
signing up will actually help countless
independent educational creators Beyond
just legal legal so sign up by clicking
on the button that's right here on
screen right now which will take you
directly to curiositystream.com
legaleagle or you can click on the link
that's in the description it's a great
way to support educational content and
get tons of exclusive content that
you'll absolutely love so click on this
link that's on screen right now or you
can click on this playlist with all of
my other YouTube videos so click here or
I'll see you in court